welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we break down all of the
latest movies new game releases TV shows
and comic books for episode three of
crisis on Infinite Earths it's better
the devil you know as we watch our
heroes go through hell in order to get
all of us soul back there's a ton of
Easter eggs big moments and a huge
cliffhanger that will be breaking down
throughout this video just in case you
missed anything now obviously there's
gonna be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to watch the
episode yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of crisis on Infinite Earths
episode 3 okay everyone so before we get
into the latest episode we just kind of
need to recap the last entry of Black
Lightning that had yesterday though this
wasn't initially confirmed as part of
the crisis lineup we do know for
definite now that the character is
included and features in this episode
are quite a big moment lightning was
brought across the multiverse in the
closing scene of his own show yesterday
after his earth was destroyed and he
joins the team in the Sentry helping out
during one of the major flash scenes so
yeah just a little side note there in
case there was any confusion as to why's
here for a couple of minutes I haven't
done a breakdown of their episode so I
just thought I'd add it in at the start
of this one now crisis episode 3 opens
in new Gotham on Earth 203 with Huntress
on the run from the red wave of death
this is the same continuity as the
short-lived DC TV show birds of prey and
before we even get to say hello to the
characters the universe is wiped out in
an instant
we then travel to earth one namely the
Waverider where the flash arrives with
Cisco and the rest of the team in order
to fix Palmer's Paragon finder if one is
sort of becoming the main evacuation
point of the multiverse and time is
running out for the heroes to save the
existence of all realities
luckily they discover the other
remaining Paragons which are made up of
Martian Manhunter the flash and a guy
named Ryan Choi a physics professor Ryan
is just the paragon of humanity and this
is why he's just a regular guy now the
groups are out to meet him and
they do he does the classic line you
know the one where a scientist meets
another scientist and says your paper on
their overly long signs would change my
blah blah blah you know the line I
minded it in Avengers remember yeah well
they do it here just not as well choi
takes some convincing from iris to leave
his family as the newly introduced
character is afraid of walker come but
eventually she manages to make him see
the bigger picture he joins the team and
it's gonna be kind of interesting to see
what he actually brings to the table as
for the most part he seems pretty
useless I don't know maybe you can
assemble IKEA furniture really well
maybe he's a great actor maybe not look
I don't know I don't know what the
paragon of humanity can do but yeah it's
nice that they have a little wild-card
amongst their ranks elsewhere on the
Waverider Diggle discovers that Oliver
died during the initial episode and that
the group tried to revive him to no
avail this sends them on a quest to
travel to purgatory in order to try and
bring all his soul back to his body and
along with Sara Mia and Constantine they
go to earth 666 and run into none other
than Lucifer played by Tom Ellis it's
great seeing the character back even if
his appearance is really short-lived and
similar to Oliver Lucifer has been
killed off well canceled a couple of
times now so it's nice that he was at
least included in this plot that send it
around resurrection and revival however
as with the first two episodes the
character doesn't really get much room
to breathe and once more I think Crysis
suffers from an extremely fast pace that
has many moments just rushing by before
you can even catch your breath to me it
just feels like there's too much going
on at once and it makes it difficult to
really invest in any of the scenes
because of how fast they Wis past
personally I feel like before you start
to engage with what's going on you're
already off to the next moment and yeah
I just wish they'd given the creative
team more space when developing this
storyline I got some flak yesterday for
criticizing the Tom Welling cameo so I'm
just gonna kind of discuss that more as
I think it paints out a lot of my
feelings towards this episode as well so
when it came to Tom Welling I felt like
the entire time he was there they just
stood him in one spot and had some
characters walk up to him then walk off
then
other characters walk up to him and
disappear there wasn't really much
dynamism to his cameo
whereas Conroy got a lot more to play
with Lucifer kinda falls victim did the
same thing that Welling did but she did
at least have a purpose whereas Wellings
appearance didn't really help the plot
anyway that's just my two pennies on the
cameos overall so if you disagree with
me then make sure you let me know with
the help of Lucifer the group find a way
to travel to purgatory through the use
of a magic card that also sets a time
limit for them purgatory looks exactly
like Lian Yu
that's not some Chinese woman called
Lian by the way that's a real place and
his lip service paid to the fact that
souls choose their own personal hell's
and as the island is tied so heavily to
all of his life he has returned there
just before the transference of all of
his soul into his body Jim Corrigan
appears who as many of you will know was
the specter in the comic books he
convinces Oliver to take up the mantle
of the character which if he'd been
keeping up to date with the channel was
a big prediction that we made in the
first episode I'm not patting myself on
the back with that anyway I'm not
special though it was just kind of
obvious the specter of course is a huge
part of the original crisis on Infinite
Earths graphic novel and he will no
doubt be instrumental in taking down the
anti-monitor in the book the
anti-monitor is initially defeated by
the heroes and thus he decides to travel
back in time to the creation of the
multiverse in order to destroy it before
it's even created the spectre is the one
that wants the heroes of this and he's
also the character that allows them to
travel back to the initial moment in
order to stop the villain from
succeeding in his plan here I think the
spectre will play an even more prominent
role and be the one that takes the
character down completely as the
anti-monitor grows in strength the
monitor loses his and nurse we need a
high powered being in order to fight the
anti-monitor on a level playing field
Cara and Kate confront LexA with the
book of destinies powers with the formal
wishing to use it to save her earth and
all of the other realities that have
been destroyed Kate isn't too happy with
it and we keep seeing her look at a
Kryptonite like the screenshots you have
of your mates what's that messages just
in case they ever decide to make you
look stupid on Twitter I do think that
they will end up reviving the doomed
earth through this method but it will
come at the cost of their friendship as
the two will likely go head-to-head over
the matter either way there's gonna be a
million porn parodies
from this episode because man that
standoff it was hot it was hot
Kate tries to give Cara the Kryptonite
but she refuses it saying she should
keep it just in case it looks like
Supergirl isn't gonna revive the
universe's just yet but yeah how else
are they gonna film all of the new
seasons of Titan black lightning and so
on elsewhere in the episode Cisco and
killer frost managed to track down the
source of the wave of destruction
ripping across the multiverse which is
located in central city on earth one
when investigating it they come
face-to-face with the pariah a man
cursed to travel throughout the
multiverse to witness tragedy at
deferring the anti-monitor Cisco
reinstated with his vibe powers is able
to pull memories from the pariah and
through this they gain access to the
anti monitors hidden layer joined by
Barry they find the flash from earth 90
played by none other than John Wesley
Shipp the flash has been trapped inside
a treadmill which is being used to
generate power for the antimatter cannon
that is currently tearing across all
realities they managed to free the earth
Knight II version but he reveals that
the anti-monitor put a fail-safe in that
will send out a giant wave destroying
everything if he stops powering the
device I don't know I don't know why I
didn't just send that out anyway as he
was supposed to want to destroy the
multiverse but maybe maybe his heart's
just not in it it's a bit like this
breakdown the pariah disappears but
returns with black lightning who
attempts to absorb the reaction
unfortunately he fails to contain it and
this calls for desperate measures this
is where the big callback to the comics
comes in and it looks like it will be
the apparent death of Barry Allen who
says that he's willing to take the place
on the treadmill however in the last
second earth 90s flash absorbs Barry
Speed Force which makes him collapse and
this allows the elder to take his place
as the flash that dies during the crisis
he ends up running into nothing and
destroys the cannon thus stopping the
wave now this is a plot moment that
we've been waiting for since pretty much
episode 1 of the original season of the
flash I was always kind of hoping that
Barry would be the one to do it however
I wasn't too annoyed by this change up I
can see a lot of people rolling their
eyes at it though as this was a
last-minute save that didn't really feel
that earned especially for all of the
serve that we've had over the years it
doesn't mean that the flash can live to
fight another day though and
perhaps all of his sacrifice did in turn
actually say berry as was part of his
deal with the monitor obviously let me
know your thoughts on that moment as I
can see opinions being split on it but
ship got his moment at least and there
was even a call back to his original
show in the 90s transported away by vibe
the group returned to the Waverider and
learned that almost every reality has
been wiped out berry and Jefferson have
a heart-to-heart and the group become
desperate to find the Harbinger
instantly she appears and begins
attacking the heroes they try to fight
back but she easily bests them making
them do that scene and Friends where
Ross tried to hide in the bedroom it's
revealed that she's actually being
controlled by the anti-monitor and has
been sent there to destroy them but
luckily the monitor is there to fight
back the monitor sacrifices himself to
buy them time but the anti-monitor still
succeeds and destroys the entire reality
this lip service paid to the ante
monitors real name which is mobius and
it makes for a nice way to end the
episode so luckily before the
destruction of the ship the pariah
teleports the remaining Paragons to
another reality that hasn't been
destroyed yet diggle's superman iris and
the rest get dusted but the group find
themselves at the vanishing point a
location outside of space and time that
is safe from the reaches of the
anti-monitor in this reality Superman is
torn apart and replaced with Lex Luthor
who used the book of Destiny to
transport himself there Lex has made
himself a Paragon and is now looking
like their only way out the monitor may
have bought them slightly more time but
time is running out and it looks like
we're gonna have to wait until January
to find out what happens next now as
mentioned earlier when we discuss the
comics from the preview it looks like
the anti-monitor is traveling to the
dawn of time in order to destroy
everything guided by the specter aka
Oliver Queen the group will likely go
there and tackle him face to face Alex
plays into it we don't know yet but
Alexander Luthor was actually a huge
reason that the heroes managed to defeat
the anti-monitor in the source material
and though he's vastly different to this
universes version I do think he will
play a more vital role going forward now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the crossover and what you want to
see in the next episode
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdowns and
of yesterday's entry would you be linked
at the end we go over everything you
need to know about it and give our
theories for the future so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to come chat
to me after the video that makes you
follow me on twitter at definition YT or
head over to my discord server which
you'd be linked in the description below
we drop videos on there early so if you
want to see stuff before anyone else and
that's the best place to be it's free to
join and we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the marble phase 3 part 2 boxer on
blu-ray which contains Black Panther
infinity war and Game Captain Marvel and
more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on
crisis in the comment section below the
one that's gonna be chosen the 15th of
December and the set will be shipped out
from then to ever gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone he takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best now see you next time take care
peace